THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. WE ARE
TREMENDOUSLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU
WOULD TAKE TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULE TO BE ABLE TO BE HERE,
TO BE ABLE TO BE HERE, TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE POTENTIAL
APPOINTEES AS WELL, BEFORE WE
CALL THE ROLL, I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK HERE TODAY.
AS EVERYONE KNOWS, WE ARE IN THE
LAST TWO WEEKS BEFORE, WE ARE
LOOKING AT OUR SUMMER WORK
PERIOD, WHICH MEANS WE ARE IN
OUR DEADLINE WEEKS OR CRUNCH
WEEKS. AND I WANT TO FIRST
APOLOGIZE DUE TO SOME ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS AND SOME ISSUES
THAT ARE IN FRONT OF THE
LEGISLATURE, I'LL BE STEPPING
OUT AND COMING BACK. AND SO I
JUST WANT TO GIVE A HEADS UP ON
THAT. I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
ALSO TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR VICE
CHAIRMAN AND VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU. WHO WILL BE STEPPING IN.
AND THEN WHEN MADAM VICE CHAIR
IS GOING TO GO PRESENT IN THE
COMMITTEE, THEN WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE MISTER VICE VICE CHAIR, BE
TAKING OVER. AND THAT IS SENATOR
LAIRD, SO YOU SEE, THERE WE GO
CHECK ON THE TITLE, SO AGAIN,
WANT TO APOLOGIZE, BUT ALSO GIVE
EVERYONE A HEADS UP. AND WE ARE
SO APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR PATIENCE
HERE TODAY AS THERE ARE SOME
MUSICAL CHAIRS DUE TO THE
LOOMING DEADLINE. WITH THAT, I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT YOU'RE
LEAVING LAIRD AND MYSELF
UNSUPERVISED FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME. DEAR LORD, LOCK THE DOORS,
EVERYBODY. SO EXACTLY. WATCH
OUT. I LIKE IT ALL RIGHT, WHY
DON'T WE, ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
CALL THE ROLL? MAGUIRE HERE.
MAGUIRE HERE. GROVE. GROVE HERE.
EGGMAN! JONES! HERE. JONES. HERE
LAIRD. HERE. LAIRD. HERE CORMAN
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SO WHAT? WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO DO IS GET THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PORTION OF
TODAY'S HEARING. THERE ARE GOING
TO BE SEVERAL ITEMS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BRING FORWARD. ITS
GOING TO TAKE US ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES, ONCE WE HAVE COMPLETED
THAT, WE'RE GOING TO BRING IN
OUR SHERIFF'S UP AND WE'RE GOING
TO WELCOME THEM WHO ARE HERE ON
THE COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. WE'RE SO
GRATEFUL THAT BOTH OF YOU ARE
HERE. SO LET'S GET GOING. LET'S
FIRST TAKE A LOOK AT GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. WE HAVE QUITE A DOCKET
IN FRONT OF US TODAY. THIS IS
ITEMS TWO E THROUGH L TÔI
THROUGH L. IF THERE ARE NO
OBJECTIONS, WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION SO
MOVED. SIR, WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MADAM VICE CHAIR. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MCGUIRE. AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. GROVE GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN.
JONES. AYE JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. UNCLE THAT IS
A40 VOTE. FOUR ZERO VOTE. WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THAT ITEM ON CALL
FOR SENATOR EGGMAN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. COMMITTEE. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO THE
ISSUE OF BILL REFERRALS. THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE. IS THERE A
MOTION FOR APPROVAL? WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MADAM VICE CHAIR.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
EGGMAN. JONES A JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. UNCLE
FOUR ZERO. VOTE FOR ZERO. VOTE.
THAT ITEM IS ON CALL. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE ADVANCING TO THE
ISSUE OF FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS.
FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS IS ITEMS
FOUR THROUGH NINE, ITEMS FOUR
THROUGH NINE. IS THERE A MOTION
FOR APPROVAL? WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MADAM VICE CHAIR, MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MCGUIRE. AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. GROVE. GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN.
JONES AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. UNCLE THAT IS
A40 VOTE. FOUR ZERO VOTE. WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE THAT ON CALL FOR
SENATOR EGGMAN. LOOK AT THAT. WE
ARE ROLLING. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
WELCOME OUR TWO SHERIFFS SO THEY
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD, WE
ARE GOING TO BE TAKING UP BOTH
SHERIFF BRAUN AND SHERIFF MOON,
AND UNDER THEIR, ADDITIONAL
TITLE OF MEMBER. BOARD MEMBER OF
THE COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING, WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO,
MADAM, SHERIFFS, IS THAT YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE TWO MINUTES TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH
YOUR OPENING TESTIMONY. WE'RE
THEN GOING TO OPEN IT UP FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO
ASK ANY QUESTIONS AND ADVANCE
COMMENTS. WE WELCOME YOU TO,
ADVANCE ANY INTRODUCTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE OF GUESTS THAT ARE HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS AND OR WATCHING
ONLINE. AND I'LL GIVE YOU A 32ND
PROMPT AS WE GET CLOSE TO THAT
TWO MINUTES. SO WHY DON'T WE
START WITH SHERIFF BRAUN, WANT
TO SAY GOOD AFTERNOON. AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO SHERIFF MOON.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME
AND DRIVING IN. IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU. THANK YOU. CHAIR MCGUIRE,
VICE CHAIR, GROVE MEMBERS. LET
ME START WITH EXPLAINING WHY I
TALK FUNNY. I HAD A TRAUMATIC
MOUNTAIN BIKE ACCIDENT ABOUT A
TWO AND A HALF WEEKS AGO, AND,
I'VE HAD SURGERY IN MY MOUTH, SO
THE HEALING PROCESS IS NOT QUITE
THERE YET, SO I HAVE A
TEMPORARY, HOPEFULLY, SPEECH
IMPEDIMENT, SO I SPEAK FUNNY AND
I CAN'T SAY WORDS LIKE FUNNY OR
BUNNY OR HONEY, HEY, THERE WE
GO. BUT I TRY, I AM GOOD. YOU'RE
ALL GOOD. THANK YOU. I AM JOINED
HERE ONLINE BY MY HUSBAND,
MICHAEL BRAUN. HE'S RETIRED LAW
ENFORCEMENT. HE'S AT HOME IN
MAMMOTH LAKES. MY FATHER IS
WATCHING FROM LA CRESCENTA,
CALIFORNIA, AND MY SISTER, ERIKA
BACHMAN HAS JOINED ME. SHE CAME
OVER FROM OAKLAND, AND I AM JUST
PLEASED TO BE HERE. AND JOINED
BY MY PEER AND MY GOOD FRIEND,
SHERIFF MOON. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL. ERICA.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE TODAY. AND
IT'S GREAT THAT MICHAEL IS
WATCHING ONLINE AS WELL. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
SHERIFF MOON. SHERIFF MOON, WHY
DON'T YOU ADVANCE YOUR OPENING
TESTIMONY? THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
PRESENT TODAY FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION, FOR YOUR STAFF'S
TIME. ALSO, LEADING UP TO THIS
HEARING, WE'VE HAD SOME GREAT
CONVERSATIONS, WITH ME TODAY IS
A FEW PEOPLE THAT I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE NOT ONLY IN MY LIFE
AND GUIDANCE THROUGH SUPPORT OF
BEING THE SHERIFF OF MY
HOMETOWN, BUT ALSO LEADS ME
TODAY TO BEING, POTENTIALLY
APPOINTED AS GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
APPOINTEE TO THE POST COMMISSION
HERE TODAY WITH ME IS MY WIFE,
AMY MOON, ONE OF MY AMAZING
DAUGHTERS, MALLORY BORREGO, AND
TWO OF MY GREAT FRIENDS, JEREMY
WILSON, WHO IS A SENIOR PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AUTHORITY. AND MY GOOD
FRIEND LISA SWARTHOUT, WHO IS A
DISTRICT THREE SUPERVISOR IN MY
COUNTY AT HOME, MY PARENTS, MY
DAD IS A 29 YEAR RETIRED VETERAN
PEACE OFFICER. MY MOM, EILEEN
MOON, MY BROTHERS, MY BROTHER
AND SISTER, CLARA, JIMMY AND
CORAL AND MY TWO OTHER AMAZING
DAUGHTERS THAT COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY, KATIE AND ABBY BORREGO
AND ALL THE STAFF BACK AT THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE THAT ARE
WATCHING, CHEERING ME ON THAT I
GET TO REPRESENT. I LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR QUESTIONS AND GOING
ALONG IN THE PROCESS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, SHERIFF. VERY GRATEFUL.
AND IT'S WONDERFUL TO HAVE AMY
MALLORY AND OF COURSE, JEREMY
AND THE SUPERVISOR HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WHY DON'T WE
OPEN IT UP FOR CONVERSATION?
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS, FROM THE
COMMITTEE, PLEASE. YES, SENATOR.
LARRY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU BOTH
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE
AND I'M SORRY I DIDN'T GET A
CHANCE TO MEET. EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE MET IN OTHER OCCASIONS. I
THOUGHT ONE QUESTION AND START
WITH SHERIFF MOON. AND THEN IF
SHERIFF BRAUN WANTS TO ADD. BOTH
OF YOU ARE SHERIFFS OF, SMALL
RURAL COUNTIES, AND YOU'RE ON
THIS BOARD FOR STANDARDS THAT
REALLY DEALS ACROSS THE STATE.
BECAUSE THE OTHER THING I WANT
TO ASK ABOUT USE OF FORCE,
MAYBE, IS JUST SO TOTALLY
DIFFERENT IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE. WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU
BRING BY BEING A SHERIFF FROM
WHERE YOU ARE, TO THIS STATEWIDE
BODY? WHAT WHAT SORT OF UNIQUE
ABOUT COMING FROM A RURAL AREA
AND BEING ABLE TO HELP FOCUS
OTHER PEOPLE ON, ON ISSUES
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH? THANK YOU,
SENATOR, FOR THE QUESTION, BEING
FROM A RURAL, RURAL COMMUNITY, I
THINK, YOU KNOW, THE DIFFERENCE
IS EVERYONE KNOWS YOU AND I GREW
UP WITH A FATHER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT, IN A RURAL
COMMUNITY, AND EVERYONE KNEW WHO
HE WAS, WHO I WAS. AND PART OF
THAT IS THAT REPUTATION THAT YOU
ARE BRINGING FORWARD EVERY
SINGLE DAY BY WHO YOU REPRESENT.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE,
WE, WE TRULY CHERISH AT THAT
RURAL ENVIRONMENT OF PEOPLE
KNOWING WHO YOU ARE, KNOWING
WHAT YOU REPRESENT AND JUST
REALLY BEING A PART OF THE
COMMUNITY AND BEING, YOU KNOW,
AT A STATEWIDE LEVEL, YOU KNOW,
I'VE HAD NOTHING BUT BUT GREAT
CONVERSATION WITH MY PEERS THAT
ARE IN THE LARGER AGENCIES THAT
ALSO DO HAVE THAT SMALL
COMMUNITY EVENT IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS. IT'S JUST ALL IN
CONTEXT. AND I THINK WE ALL HAVE
SOMETHING TO BRING. AND, JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT WE HAVE
THAT COME FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND WE'RE ALL
WILLING AND WANT TO SERVE IN THE
MOST NOBLEST POSITION, IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. AND, SHERIFF BRAUN, I KNOW
YOU SAID YOU CAN'T SAY BUNNY AND
FUNNY AND ALL THESE THINGS, BUT
I WILL FRY. WELL, I, I WAS
WORRIED YOU'RE GOING TO SAY WE
NEED MORE MONEY AND I COULD SAY
MONEY. THAT WORD ACTUALLY WORKS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. AND
IT IS FAIR TO SAY THAT RURAL
SHERIFFING IS DIFFERENT THAN
URBAN POLICING, WHERE I LIVE, IN
TOWN OF 8000 PEOPLE, YOU CAN'T
GO ANYWHERE WITHOUT SEEING
SOMEONE YOU KNOW, AND IT'S QUITE
AMAZING. AND A REALLY GREETS ME
AND SAYS, HEY SHERIFF, HOW'S IT
GOING? AND GREET ME LIKE THEY
KNOW ME. SOMETIMES THEY DON'T,
SOMETIMES THEY DO, BUT IT'S
COMFORTING TO KNOW THAT YOU LIVE
IN A SMALL TOWN AND ARE SMALL.
MY COMMUNITY, MONROE COUNTY, IS
14,000 PEOPLE, BUT IT'S OVER
3500MI², BUT EVERYBODY KNOWS WHO
I AM, AND I LOVE THAT. I ALSO
HAVE THE ADVANTAGE OF. I HAD A
21 YEAR CAREER IN LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT. SO I GET THE
URBAN SIDE OF POLICING AS WELL.
AND SO BRINGING THAT TO THE POST
COMMISSION, I'VE I'VE BEEN IN A
BIG CITY AND NOW I'VE BEEN IN A
RURAL COUNTY. AND SO THE BALANCE
OF IT, I CAN SEE IT FROM BOTH
SIDES AND IT, IT IS VERY
DIFFERENT. AND THINKING AHEAD TO
YOUR USE OF FORCE, QUESTION, USE
OF FORCE IN AN URBAN SETTING
WHERE YOU HAVE TWO PERSON CARS
RESPONDING TO A CALL AND YOUR
BACKUP IS A MINUTE AWAY IN AN IN
A RURAL SETTING, YOU'RE BY
YOURSELF AND YOUR NEAREST BACKUP
COULD BE TWO HOURS AWAY. SO
YOU'VE GOT TO LEARN HOW TO HOW
TO DEAL ON YOUR OWN, FIGHT FOR
YOUR LIFE. IF YOU HAVE TO. SO IT
IS IT IS VERY DIFFERENT. AND SO
WE APPROACH IT DIFFERENTLY, BUT
WE CAN BRING THAT TO THE POST
COMMISSION. SO A LOT OF OUR LAWS
ARE WRITTEN FOR URBAN AREAS, AND
WE CAN BRING THE RURAL
PERSPECTIVE AND SAY, THIS IS HOW
WE HAVE TO DO IT HERE, SO I
THINK WE BRING A AS RURAL
SHERIFFS A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
THAT IS MUCH NEEDED ON THE POST
COMMISSION. REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT ANSWER. THAT'S SORT OF, TO
BE HONEST, WHAT I WAS FISHING
FOR. AND SO I'M GLAD. AND I KNOW
THAT THAT YOU SERVE WITH ONE OF
MY FAVORITE SHERIFFS, TINA
NIETO, AND IT IS VERY FUNNY
BECAUSE SHE GREW UP IN THE LOS
ANGELES. I KNEW HER THERE AS
WELL DEPARTMENT. AND NOW SHE HAS
RURAL AREAS, AND IT'S SO WEIRD
TO FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
POLICE ESCORT IN BIG SUR, SHE
NAVIGATES THAT THING WITH THE
RURAL IN A STRANGE WAY. AND THEN
LET'S ASK JUST ABOUT WHERE WE
ARE. WHERE YOU THINK ARE SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT MIGHT BE
REMAINING WITH USE OF FORCE
BECAUSE THAT'S SORT OF GOT
TOSSED TO YOU IN MANY WAYS. AND
I DON'T KNOW, SHERIFF MOON, IF
YOU'D LIKE. I JUST THOUGHT IT
MIGHT BE EASIER IF YOU GO FIRST
AND SHERIFF BRAUN COULD GO. ME
TOO, IF SHE WANTS TO. YOU BET.
YOU BET. ME TOO. OF COURSE, YOU
KNOW. YEAH. USE OF FORCE, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE CONSTANTLY LOOKING
AT WAYS TO IMPROVE, AND I. AND I
THINK THAT IS, THE CALIFORNIA
WAY, WE LEAD THE, THE, THE
NATION TRULY, IN A LOT OF THE
STANDARDS AND THE REGULATIONS
THAT WE DO HAVE. AND WE HAVE TO
WE HAVE TO BE NIMBLE, TO BE ABLE
TO SEE WHAT'S COMING NEXT AND
WHAT OUR COMMUNITIES WANT FROM
US AND EXPECT FROM US. AND IT'S
NOT JUST, BEING A 34 YEAR
VETERAN OF DOING THIS JOB OF
WHAT I THINK NEEDS TO HAPPEN, WE
DO HAVE TO LISTEN TO OUR
COMMUNITIES CONTINUALLY TO SEE
WHAT LEVELS, WE SHOULD WE SHOULD
BE IN OUR PERFORMANCE. AND, YOU
KNOW, THE DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES
AND THE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
THAT ARE CONSTANTLY EVOLVING.
AND WE'RE AT THE REALLY IN
CALIFORNIA VÀ, AT THE LEAD IN
SOME OF THOSE AREAS SO THAT WE
CAN KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE,
OUR COPS SAFE. AND WHEN ALL
THOSE THINGS ARE IN LINE, IT'S A
WONDERFUL THING. AND THOSE ARE
THE THINGS THAT THAT I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUALLY SEE
IN CALIFORNIA. YEAH. GREAT.
THANK YOU. AND MORE THAN ME,
TOO. I DIDN'T REALIZE I HAD
SOMETHING ELSE IN COMMON WITH
SHERIFF MOON. 34 YEARS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. DEFINITELY ME TO
WHAT SHERIFF MOON SAID, BUT ALSO
, THE TECHNOLOGY PIECE OF IT,
THE BODY WORN CAMERAS, THE
IN-CAR VIDEO, EVERYTHING OUR
OFFICERS, OUR DEPUTIES DO IS
ALWAYS ON CAMERA ALL THE TIME.
AND THEY'RE QUITE COMFORTABLE
WITH IT AND THEY'RE AWARE OF IT
ALL THE TIME. AND IT, I WOULDN'T
SAY IT MODERATES THEIR BEHAVIOR,
BUT IT REMINDS THEM TO ALWAYS
ACT APPROPRIATELY AND DO WHAT
THEY HAVE TO DO AND DO IT RIGHT.
SO EVERYTHING IS ALWAYS CAPTURED
, AND IT'S A BENEFIT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES SO THAT THEY CAN GO
BACK AND SEE. I EVEN HAD
SOMEBODY COME IN AND MAKE A
COMPLAINT, BRING THEM INTO THE
OFFICE A WEEK AFTER, LET HER
WATCH THE WHOLE VIDEO ALL THE
WAY THROUGH. AND THEN SHE SAID,
OH, I DIDN'T SEE IT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE. AND THEN AND SHE
WASN'T EVEN PERCIPIENT TO IT.
SHE JUST SAW IT ON THE SIDE OF
THE STREET. AND I SAID, COME IN
AND COME LOOK AT THE VIDEO. SO
IT'S, HELPFUL TO HAVE THAT TO
SHOW TO OUR COMMUNITIES THAT WE
ARE DOING THE RIGHT THINGS FOR
THE RIGHT REASONS. THANK YOU. I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU
BOTH. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY, PLEASE, SENATOR AIKMAN,
HI. THANK YOU, I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T GET TO MEET WITH YOU
EITHER, I GUESS MY QUESTION IS I
SAW A, AS WE WERE ALL MORNING.
IF YOU'RE FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, WILLIE MAYS, WHO
DIED, AND THERE'S A LOT OF
PICTURES GOING AROUND. AND ONE
OF THE PICTURES, SOME OF THE
SENATORS, SENATOR BROWN WAS HE
CAME TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR IN
2010. AND AS I WAS LOOKING AT ON
ALL THE MEMBERS ARE ALL LINED
UP. AND AS I WAS LOOKING AT ALL
THE MEMBERS, THEY WERE IT WAS
OVERWHELMINGLY WHITE AND MALE
AND I LOOK AT US NOW AND I THINK
WHAT A DIFFERENCE A DECADE HAS
MADE. THAT'S THROUGH A LOT OF
VERY INTENTIONAL WORK TO CHANGE
THE MAKEUP OF THE LEGISLATURE AS
WOMEN. HOW HAVE YOU SEEN THAT
CHANGE OVER TIME, AND HOW DO YOU
SEE IT PLAYING INTO YOUR ROLE,
IF AT ALL? THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION, SENATOR. WHEN I CAME
ON LAPD IN 1990, THERE WAS A
CELEBRATION BECAUSE WE HIT 15%
WOMEN AND I THOUGHT, THAT'S IT.
WE'RE 50% OF THE POPULATION, BUT
WE'RE ONLY 15% OF THE OF THE
JOB. AND IT'S STILL HOVERS
AROUND THAT AREA. AND WHEN I
CAME TO MONO COUNTY, I WAS THE
SECOND FEMALE EVER IN 2012, EVER
, I NOW HAVE MORE FEMALE
DEPUTIES. WE HAVE NATIVE,
BECAUSE WE HAVE A NATIVE
POPULATION IN MONO COUNTY, IT
TAKES EFFORT. YOU GOT TO RECRUIT
FROM THE COMMUNITY. YOUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD REFLECT THE
COMMUNITY IT SERVES. AND WE'RE
NOT THERE YET WITH WOMEN. IT'S A
DEMANDING JOB, AND WE ARE STILL
EXPECTED TO BE MOTHERS AND WIVES
AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS AND DO
THIS JOB. AND IT'S HARD TO DO
SHIFT WORK AND DO THAT, BUT
WE'RE GETTING THERE AND
CERTAINLY IT HAS CHANGED JUST IN
THE TEN YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN THE
SHERIFF, I'VE GONE FROM 1 TO 4,
AND THAT'S JUST ON THE SWORN
SIDE ON THE ON THE CORRECTIONAL
SIDE, I AM 50% FEMALE, SO IT
JUST TAKES THE WORK AND SETTING
THE EXAMPLE. AND I THINK THAT'S
WHY IT HELPS TO HAVE LEADERS WHO
ARE REFLECT THE COMMUNITY THAT
THAT WE SERVE, UP HERE AND
REPRESENTING. THE TO SEE
YOURSELF SOMEWHERE. I THINK IS A
IS A BENEFIT. SO THE VISUAL OF
SEEING WOMEN IN CHARGE,
ESPECIALLY IN A IN A RURAL
COMMUNITY WHERE WE MIGHT NOT SEE
A LOT OF FEMALE DEPUTY SHERIFFS,
YOU KNOW, THE, THE DIFFERENCE IN
IT'S NOT THE VERB OF
RECRUITMENT. IT'S CHANGING THE
CULTURE OF YOUR AGENCY SO THAT
WOMEN WANT TO WORK IN YOUR
INDUSTRY. IT'S AN AMAZING
INDUSTRY TO BE ABLE TO HELP
PEOPLE ON THE WORST DAYS OF
THEIR LIVES. AND ENSURING THAT
WOMEN UNDERSTAND THAT WE NEED
THEM, WE NEED THEIR PERSPECTIVE,
AND WE CAN BE A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBLE, WITH WITH OUR
SCHEDULES, WE'RE PARAMILITARY.
SO WE'VE DONE THINGS THE WAY
WE'VE DONE THINGS FOR THE SINCE
THE START OF TIME, BECAUSE IT'S
JUST THE WAY WE DO THINGS, AND
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE
THAT, THAT, THAT, PERSPECTIVE OF
SO THAT WE CAN ATTRACT MORE
WOMEN INTO THE WORKFORCE IN
POLICING. AND WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
THE EXAMPLES OF THE BENEFITS OF
BEING A MORE DIVERSE, WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH GENDER, THROUGH
RACE. IT JUST IS A COLLECTIVE OF
HOW YOU POLICE A COMMUNITY
SHOULD BE THE COMMUNITY POLICES
ITSELF WITH US, NOT NOT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND. THANK YOU
MA'AM, THANK YOU. PLEASE, MADAM
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR
, HONOR, I YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST
MY HONOR THAT YOU'RE SITTING
BEFORE ME AND THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAD THE WISDOM TO APPOINT YOU,
YOU TO SHERIFF BRAUN, BUT I'VE
KNOWN SHERIFF MOON FOR A LONG
TIME, AND THE UTMOST RESPECT FOR
YOU, MA'AM. JUST THE UTMOST
RESPECT FOR YOU AND WHAT YOU DO
IN THE LEADERSHIP THAT YOU
PROVIDE TO YOUR PEOPLE. I DO
HAVE A QUESTION REGARDING A
POST, THOUGH, ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
, 2022 CRIME REPORT IN
CALIFORNIA SHOWED THAT CRIME IS
INCREASED ROUGHLY 17 OR, EXCUSE
ME, 8% FROM 178,000 ROUGHLY
CRIMES 193,000 CRIMES IN JUST A
FEW YEARS, IS THERE NEW TRAINING
OR SOMETHING? BECAUSE CRIME IS
DIFFERENT NOW OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS THAN IT WAS BEFORE. I
MEAN, I MEAN, IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN THE LAST DECADE, OBVIOUSLY.
I MEAN, I THINK WHEN WE WERE ALL
GROWING UP, WE PLAYED ON THE
STREET. WHEN THE LIGHTS CAME ON,
WE WENT HOME. YOU KNOW, KIDS
DON'T DO THAT ANYMORE. IT'S NOT
ALLOWED. IT'S NOT SAFE. IS THERE
A DIFFERENT TRAINING OR
SOMETHING THAT YOU GUYS ARE
GOING TO DEVELOP TO HELP, LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEAL WITH THIS TYPE
OF CRIME, ESPECIALLY IN THE FACE
, IN MY VIEWPOINT. AND NOT
EVERYBODY'S IN THE FACE OF THE,
COMPLETE DISRESPECT THAT
INDIVIDUALS, SOME INDIVIDUALS
HAVE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT. I MEAN
, I DON'T KNOW, MY MOM TAUGHT ME
WHEN IF YOU GOT PULLED OVER, YOU
PUT YOUR HANDS AT TEN AND TWO
AND IT'S YES OR NO, SIR. YES,
MA'AM. NO, MA'AM. RIGHT BUT NOW
IT'S LIKE FREE STOP AND NO. AND
THEY JUST SO I GUESS THERE'S GOT
TO BE TRAINING OR SOMETHING
DEVELOPED TO DEAL WITH THE, THE
SITUATION THAT WE HAVE IN, IN,
OUR CRIME SITUATION THAT WE HAVE
NOW. SO ARE YOU GUYS LOOKING AT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT OR NOT?
THANK YOU. SENATOR YOU KNOW, THE
REALITY OF ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
THAT TRUST WITHIN COMMUNITY, SO
THAT WHEN THE, WHEN CRIME DOES
OCCUR, THAT PEOPLE WILL CALL
CRIME IN BECAUSE ONE OF THE
DIFFICULT ISSUES SOMETIMES IS
THAT WE CAN ONLY, THE DATA ON
CRIME IS ONLY WHAT GETS REPORTED
AND WHAT WHEN WHAT WE VISUALIZE.
THERE'S SO MUCH CRIME THAT DOES
NOT GET REPORTED IN IN NOT JUST
IN CALIFORNIA, BUT EVERYWHERE,
AND IN ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
TRUST OF A COMMUNITY TO ONE
REPORT CRIME. SO THAT WE ARE
FOLLOWING UP AND DOING THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO TO
SOLVE CRIME AND HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR, FOR CRIMINAL
ACTS, SO THE, THE TRAINING IS
ALL ENCOMPASSING OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY, THAT WE ARE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE'RE
LISTENING TO OUR COMMUNITY, AND
THAT YOU KNOW, AS, AS
LEGISLATORS, WHEN WE BRING IN
NEW CRIME OR CHANGE CRIME
STATUTES, MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
ALL STAYING, UP TO DATE ON ALL
OF THOSE THINGS BECAUSE IT CAN
BE VERY DIFFICULT. IT CHANGES,
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES IN WITHIN
MONTHS, WITHIN YEARS OF ONE
CRIME BEING A CRIME AND THEN AND
THEN CHANGING. SO JUST MAKING
SURE THAT WE, WE, HAVE STAFF
THAT, THAT ARE CONSTANT LEARNERS
THAT LEARN AND STAY IN THE
PROCESS. AND, AND WE'RE POST IS
CONSTANTLY LOOKING AT WAYS TO,
TO DO BETTER FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
FOR SURE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
TAGGING ON TO WHAT, SHERIFF MOON
SAID, POST IS ALWAYS REVIEWING
TRAINING AND LOOKING AT THE
EFFICACY OF THE TRAINING. AND IS
THIS TRAINING WORKING AND IS IT
THE RIGHT TRAINING AND IS IT THE
RIGHT PLATFORM, WE DID HAVE A
PERIOD DURING THE PANDEMIC WHERE
EVERYTHING WAS ONLINE AND ALL
THE TRAINING WAS ONLINE, AND YOU
LOSE SOMETHING WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE THE IN-PERSON THING. SO A
LOT OF TRAINING HAS GONE BACK TO
IN-PERSON. BUT FOR US WHO LIVE
REMOTELY AND IF I SEND SOMEBODY
TO TRAINING, IT'S EXPENSIVE TO
SEND SOMEBODY OFF TO TRAINING.
THEN YOU GOT TO BACKFILL AND YOU
GOT TO PAY FOR THEM TO GO. BUT
IT'S WORTH IT TO SEND THEM TO
THAT TRAINING. SO THAT THEY CAN
MEET PEERS FROM OTHER COUNTIES,
OTHER AGENCIES, AND LEARN WHAT
OTHER CITIES ARE DOING AND OTHER
COUNTIES ARE DOING AND HOW
THEY'RE ATTACKING THEIR THEIR
CRIME PROBLEMS. AND EVERY CRIME
PROBLEM IS GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
FOR EVERY AREA. LIKE, I DON'T
HAVE A BIG RETAIL THEFT PROBLEM
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE BIG RETAIL
STORES, SO IT'S ALWAYS DIFFERENT
FOR EVERYBODY. BUT POST, LOOKS
AT THE TRAINING CONSTANTLY. AND
IS IT WORKING? AND THEY, THEY
GET FEEDBACK FROM THE STUDENTS
WHAT DID YOU LIKE ABOUT THIS
COURSE? WHAT WASN'T GOOD ABOUT
THIS COURSE? WHAT WOULD BE
BETTER ABOUT THIS COURSE, WHAT
WAS GREAT ABOUT THIS COURSE, AND
LOOKING AT THE TRAINING AND
SEEING WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN'T WORK, AND ALWAYS
ADJUSTING IT AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE BEST TRAINING IS
GETTING OUT THERE TO THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BOTH. DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE DAIS?
SO THIS IS AT THE TIME WHEN WE
GO TO SUPPORT, INDIVIDUALS THAT
WANT TO COME UP AND SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THESE NOMINEES,
PLEASE COME FORWARD. AND WE
PRESUME THE FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THEM. WE'RE
PRESUMING PRESUMING AMY'S IN
SUPPORT. YES. OKAY. IT'S WE'RE
KIND OF A TWEENER. NO. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS, CORY SALZILLO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, PROUD TO
SUPPORT BOTH THESE PHENOMENAL
SHERIFFS WHO SIT BEFORE YOU
TODAY WHO ARE JUST FANTASTIC
REPRESENTATIVES OF THEIR
COUNTIES. AND I FEEL A LITTLE
RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE I SUGGESTED
MAYBE THAT SHERIFF MOON WANTS TO
DO THIS, AND SHE NEVER FORGETS
TO REMIND ME THAT I WAS THE ONE
WHO MAYBE KIND OF PUT HER NAME
IN THE MIX. SO MAYBE SOMEDAY
SHE'LL FORGIVE ME. BUT I THINK
THEY'RE DOING AN EXCELLENT JOB.
AND, THEY ARE ASSETS TO THE
COMMISSION AND TO THE STATE. SO
THE ASSOCIATION IS VERY PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THEM. AND WE ASK YOUR
FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION FOR
THEIR NOMINATIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CORY. ANYONE ELSE
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
IS THERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? LAST CALL FOR
OPPOSITION. SEE I'M NOT GOING TO
OPPOSE. I'M GOING TO MAKE A
MOTION WHEN YOU'RE ALMOST DONE
WITH THIS. HE HIT HIS BUTTON. I
THOUGHT HE WANTED TO. MAYBE A
LITTLE NERVOUS, BUT COMMENT WHEN
YOU'RE READY. OKAY, SO SEEING
NONE IN OPPOSITION, WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DAIS. THANK YOU,
MADAM VICE CHAIR, SHERIFFS,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US, SHERIFF. BRIAN, DID YOU SAY
YOUR ACCIDENT WAS A MOUNTAIN
BIKING ACCIDENT? YES, SIR. IF
YOU LIVE IN THE MOUNTAINS, YOU
MUST MOUNTAIN BIKE. WELL, I LIVE
IN THE HILLS OF SAN DIEGO, AND I
BROKE MY COLLARBONE A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO, ACTUALLY, IN
RIVERSIDE. SO I HAD SURGERY TO
REPAIR MYSELF FROM A MOUNTAIN
BIKE ACCIDENT AS WELL. SO I'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY WHEN
YOU'RE BETTER, THAT MAYBE I CAN
COME UP THERE AND WE CAN GO
MOUNTAIN BIKING TOGETHER. THAT
WOULD BE LOVELY. IT'D BE GREAT,
I HAVE MOUNTAIN BIKING HERE AND
IN AUBURN AND, UP HERE IN THE
GREAT AREA. I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE ON A PERSONAL NOTE THAT
THIS IS VERY PERSONAL TO ME AS
WELL, MY SON IN LAW IS A POLICE
OFFICER IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. AND
SO, I KNOW THAT OUR OFFICERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE THE BEST TRAINED
IN THE COUNTRY, AND THAT WHEN WE
SEE IN THE PRESS AND IN THE
MEDIA CHALLENGES WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENTS AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY, THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN THE STEPS
TO, FOR LACK OF A BETTER TERM,
INOCULATE OURSELVES FROM THOSE
CHALLENGES. AND SO I ALSO SERVE
ON THE BOARD OF A NONPROFIT THAT
THAT, SUPPORTS POLICE OFFICERS
THAT ARE CATASTROPHICALLY
INJURED IN THE LINE OF DUTY OR
IF IN THE HORRIFIC CASE, THEY
COMMIT SUICIDE, WE STAND BY TO
SUPPORT THE FAMILIES THAT ARE
LEFT BEHIND IN THOSE SITUATIONS,
RECOGNIZING THAT SUICIDE IS
BECOMING A HUGE CHALLENGE IN OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIRST
RESPONDER COMMUNITIES, I KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN STEPS
FORWARD TO ADDRESS THAT, AND I
JUST WANT TO STATE THAT IF
THERE'S ANYTHING I CAN DO TO BE
HELPFUL IN THAT AVENUE, I STAND
READY TO BE HELPFUL AND SUPPORT
YOU IN THE TRAINING AND
EVERYTHING THAT YOU NEED TO DO
ON, ON THOSE ISSUES. SO I'M GLAD
TO SUPPORT, YOU KNOW, THAT YOU
HAVE AN ADVOCATE FOR POLICE
OFFICERS HERE, WITH MYSELF. AND,
YOU KNOW, THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORTS POLICE OFFICERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND, BUT I JUST WANT
TO SHARE THAT PERSONAL NOTE WITH
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR. THANK
YOU, SIR. MADAM CHAIR. YES, SIR.
I WOULD MOVE THAT. WE CONFIRM
BOTH SHERIFFS MOON AND SHERIFF
BRAUN FOR THESE POSITIONS. CAN
WE MOVE THEM TO THE FLOOR FOR
THE FULL CONFIRMATION FIRST, OR
YOU WANT TO DO THIS BY YOURSELF,
THAT WAS CLEARLY THE INFERENCE
OF THE MOTION. SO MOVED BY
SENATOR LAIRD. MADAM SECRETARY,
YOU WANT TO CALL THE ROLL?
MAGUIRE, GROW A GROVE. AYE,
EGGMAN. JONES. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. ON CALL. AND
FOR EVERYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE,
THEY LEFT US UNSUPERVISED. AND
THAT WAS PROBABLY NOT A GOOD
THING. YES. CONGRATULATIONS. YOU
GUYS ARE BOTH GOING TO THE
SENATE FLOOR, AND WE WISH YOU
BOTH THE BEST OF LUCK. OH, WE
WILL, HOLD THE ROLL OPEN. I
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE WE DO HAVE TWO
MEMBERS THAT WANT TO COME BACK
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEIR VOTE IS
COUNTED ON YOUR NOMINATION AS
WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SENATORS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A ONE MINUTE
RECESS. YES, YES, WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A ONE MINUTE RECESS WHILE
THE OTHER WHILE WE CHANGE
PLACES. AND, WE PUT ON
MICROCHIPS. SO IF YOU EVER DO
GOING TO TAKE UP THE
APPOINTMENT. SORRY OKAY. GO
AHEAD. WE'RE BACK FROM RECESS,
AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP ITEM
ONE C THE APPOINTMENT OF
ALEXANDER C, SHERIFF'S, A
JUNIOR, AN MD, AS THE MEMBER OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY UNITED
UNIFIED AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT BOARD. SO WELCOME, MR.
SHERIFFS. WE'LL GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF MINUTES TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND GIVE US A LITTLE
INFORMATION, AND THEN WE'LL
START A RIGOROUS QUESTION AND
ANSWER PROCESS. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO IT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF MY
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT BOARD. I AM A FAMILY
PHYSICIAN BORN IN CALIFORNIA
WITH MATERNAL AND PATERNAL
GRANDPARENTS WHO FARMED IN
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE LIVED IN THE
GREAT VALLEY FOR FIVE DECADES. I
COMPLETED MEDICAL SCHOOL AT UC
DAVIS, BEING DRAWN TO THAT
SCHOOL'S EMPHASIS ON PRIMARY
CARE AND SERVICE TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. MY SPOUSE AND I
TRAINED AT THE UCSF AFFILIATED
FAMILY MEDICINE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM IN FRESNO COUNTY
HOSPITAL. WE SUBSEQUENTLY
VOLUNTEERED FOR TWO YEARS WITH
THE US PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE IN
EXOTIC MICHIGAN. WE RETURNED TO
THE VALLEY WITH SOME
TREPIDATION. THE AIR QUALITY WAS
NOTORIOUS, AS WE KNEW FROM OUR
RESIDENCY YEARS. ONE DAUGHTER
BORN HERE DEVELOPED ASTHMA, BUT
WE CAME BACK TO THE VALLEY WITH
THE DESIRE AND EXPECTATION OF
ENGAGING ITS SHORTCOMINGS, AS
WELL AS ENJOYING ITS BOUNTIES
AND OPPORTUNITIES. I WAS FIRST
APPOINTED TO THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT BOARD IN 2011.
UNDER THE THEN NEW
REORGANIZATION OF THE BOARD TO
INCLUDE NOT ONLY ELECTEDS BUT
ALSO WITH TWO GOVERNORS
APPOINTEE POSITIONS TO
SPECIFICALLY REPRESENT HEALTH,
HEALTH RELATED AIR QUALITY IS
ALSO MORE THAN THE RESPIRATORY,
CARDIAC, CANCER AND COGNITIVE
ILL EFFECTS. AS A DOCTOR, I HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN INVOLVED IN TRAINING
THE NEXT GENERATION OF
PROVIDERS, TEACHING MEDICAL
STUDENTS NURSE PRACTITIONERS,
ENCOURAGING HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
TO PURSUE HEALTH CAREERS. IT IS
ESPECIALLY PAINFUL WHEN
PROFESSIONALS I HAVE HELPED
TRAIN CHOOSE TO PURSUE CAREERS
OUTSIDE OF THE VALLEY BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT WANT TO LIVE OR
RAISE A FAMILY IN AN AREA WITH
SUCH UNHEALTHY AIR QUALITY. I
HOPE YOU WILL ENDORSE MY
CONTINUING TO BUILD ON PAST
SUCCESSES WITH THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT BOARD. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU DOCTOR. WE BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? NO. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
YES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE SO LONG FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO RE-UP IT
AGAIN. THANK MY WIFE. THERE HAVE
BEEN, SOME ISSUES, JUST ABOUT
STAKEHOLDER PARTICIPATION IN THE
VALLEY BECAUSE THERE'S, AS YOU
TOUCHED ON, VARIOUS GROUPS THAT
ARE AFFECTED BY JUST WHAT THE
AIR QUALITY IS. AND THERE'S BEEN
CERTAIN LEGISLATION AS WELL TO
TRY TO WRAP GROUPS IN, IN YOUR
JOB, HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE THAT
YOU SORT OF VALUE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS OR REACH OUT TO
THEM AND SORT OF GETTING TO SOME
OF THE DECISIONS YOU HAVE TO
MAKE? PERSONALLY, I'M AVAILABLE
TO ANYONE WHO WANTS TO CONTACT
ME BEFORE A MEETING, AND HAVE
CONVERSATIONS BEFORE EVERY
MEETING WITH PEOPLE FROM THE
COMMUNITY, FROM ALL, ALL KINDS
OF STAKEHOLDERS, WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING BUSINESSES OR WE'RE
TALKING ADVOCATES OR CITIZENS, I
WOULD COMMENT, I THINK THE AIR
DISTRICT HAS VERY MUCH IMPROVED
IN TERMS OF ITS SENSE OF WHAT A
STAKEHOLDER IS OVER THE LAST
FIVE, TEN YEARS, BECAUSE
PREVIOUS TO THAT, A STAKEHOLDER
STAKEHOLDERS MEANT BUSINESSES.
AND OBVIOUSLY THOSE ARE CRITICAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE ECONOMY, TO
PEOPLE HAVING ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE, TO THE VIBRANCY OF THE
VALLEY. BUT STAKEHOLDER HAS COME
TO MEAN ANYBODY WHO BREATHES THE
VALLEY AIR. AND I THINK THAT
REALLY HAS BEEN A TRANSFORMATION
IN THE CULTURE OF THE DISTRICT
THAT I'VE SEEN WHILE I'VE BEEN A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD. SO THAT
STAKEHOLDER TAKES BROAD MEANING,
AS IT SHOULD, ANYBODY WHO'S
AFFECTED BY THE AIR QUALITY IN
THE VALLEY, I APPRECIATE THAT.
AND IT'S I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY
15 OR 17 YEARS AGO WHEN ONE OF
THE BIGGEST LEGISLATIVE FIGHTS
WAS EXPANDING THE BOARD BY SEAT
OR TWO. THAT ENDS UP BEING ONE
OF THE SEATS YOU'RE IN. AND IT
WAS TO THANK YOU FOR THAT. YEAH,
EXACTLY, MAKING SURE THAT
DIFFERENT VOICES WERE
REPRESENTED ON THE BOARD AND
THEN THE OTHER QUESTION, AND
YOU'RE REALLY EXPERIENCED AT
THIS, I WOULD JUST LIKE TO HEAR
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY, BECAUSE
YOU'VE BEEN ON THE BOARD FOR 13
YEARS. YOU'RE A MEDICAL
PRACTITIONER. AND SO YOU SEE IN
DIFFERENT WAYS WHAT IMPACTS ARE
OF BAD AIR QUALITY. HOW DO YOU
TAKE WHAT YOU MIGHT JUST LEARN
IN MEDICAL PRACTICE OR SEE ON
THE GROUND AND TRY TO REFLECT IT
FOR LAY PEOPLE THAT MAKE
DECISIONS THAT MIGHT IMPACT
THAT, HOW DO YOU TAKE THAT
EXPERIENCE AND BRING IT INTO
YOUR YOUR ROLE AS A BOARD MEMBER
? YOU KNOW, I THINK MY ROLE ON
THE BOARD IS TO REPRESENT
HEALTH. AND I THINK THERE ARE
TWO MAJOR ASPECTS TO THAT. ONE
IS, IS HELPING OTHER BOARD
MEMBERS BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
HEALTH SCIENCE, ANOTHER ASPECT
OF THAT IS TO BECAUSE INDEED THE
DISTRICT, IT'S A IT'S A PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCY. AND TO BE CERTAIN
THAT WE ARE ELEVATING HEALTH AS
WE THINK ABOUT EACH OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT THAT THAT WE
CONFRONT AND ARE TRYING TO, TO
SOLVE OF, AND SO HELPING PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE BETTER,
WHERE THE SCIENCE IS COMING FROM
, WHERE THERE'S UNCERTAINTY IN
THE SCIENCE AND WHAT THAT
UNCERTAINTY MEANS, AND, AND
CERTAINLY BEING A PHYSICIAN AND
TAKING CARE OF PATIENTS AND
SEEING THE HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
OF, OF, BAD AIR, ALLOWS ME TO
HAVE STORIES TO SHARE WITH OTHER
BOARD MEMBERS THAT I THINK CAN
CAN HELP THEM APPRECIATE, HELP
EVERYONE APPRECIATE BETTER WHAT
WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS OF THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING. AND
PARTLY THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS THAT ARE SOMETIMES
MADE. BUT WHEN PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT THIS HAS
ON INDIVIDUALS AS WELL AS
COMMUNITIES, PEOPLE CAN FEEL
BETTER ABOUT THOSE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS. THANK YOU. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT RESPONSE. AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR SERVICE
. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? THIS IS THE TIME WHEN
WE'LL OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. IF THERE'S ANYONE, IN
THE AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COME UP AND SUPPORT, DOCTOR
SHERIFFS OR PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. SYLVIA SOLIS
SHAW HERE ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY UNIFIED AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT,
DOCTOR, SHERIFF HAS PROVEN TO BE
A VERY THOUGHTFUL,
KNOWLEDGEABLE, AND PRAGMATIC
MEMBER OF THE BOARD, AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS
REAPPOINTMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. VICE CHAIR MEMBERS, I'M
TOM KNOX OF VALLEY CLEAN AIR.
NOW I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF DOCTOR SHERIFFS, WHO WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH FOR WELL OVER
A DECADE NOW, HIS QUALIFICATIONS
ARE EXCELLENT AS A DOCTOR. AND A
FARMER, HE UNDERSTANDS THE
COMPLEXITIES OF AIR QUALITY IN
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. PERSONALLY,
THOUGH, HIS ENTHUSIASM. I ALWAYS
KNOW WHEN I RUN INTO HIM, I'M
GOING TO GET A FEW THOUGHTFUL
QUESTIONS. HE'S REALLY
INTERESTED IN THE WORK WE DO,
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO GET SOME
ENCOURAGEMENT. AND BOTH SIDES OF
THAT JUST HELP ME KEEP DOING
MORE, BETTER WORK. I REALLY,
REALLY APPRECIATE THE ROLE THAT
DOCTOR SHERIFFS HAS PLAYED NOW
FOR OVER A DECADE WITH THE
VALLEY AIR DISTRICT. HE'S
SOMEONE THAT REALLY CARES AND
JUST EXUDES THAT ENTHUSIASM FOR
OUR WORK. SO THANK YOU, DOCTOR
SHERIFFS, AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
LISTENING. THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT?
WE'LL INVITE WITNESSES UP FOR
OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
? SEEING NONE IN OPPOSITION.
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS,
I WOULD MOVE THAT. WE FORWARD
THIS NOMINATION TO THE SENATE
FLOOR WITH THE APPROVAL OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE. SO MOVED. VERY
WELL. YEAH, YEAH. YOU MISSED IT.
YEAH. YOU MISSED IT EARLIER.
YEAH. THEY'RE JUST HALLMARKS OF
THE GROVE ADMINISTRATION. SO.
YEAH. MADAM SECRETARY, CALL THE
ROLL. MCGUIRE. GROVE AYE. GROVE.
AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. JONES
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE. UNCLE 4 TO 0. THANK YOU.
DOCTOR. SHERIFF'S
CONGRATULATIONS. YOU'RE GOING TO
THE FULL SENATE FLOOR. YES
BEFORE WE TAKE UP OUR NEXT
APPOINTEE, I APOLOGIZE. JUST
GIVE US ONE SECOND, SENATOR
EGGMAN WAS A BUSY AT ANOTHER
COMMITTEE, I WANT TO OPEN UP
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR, AND WE, YOU WANT TO
TAKE THEM UP INDIVIDUALLY, OR WE
CAN TAKE THEM UP ALTOGETHER.
ALTOGETHER? IS IT OKAY IF WE
TAKE THEM UP ALTOGETHER? SO SO,
ITEM. ONE A, B, C AND D,
CORRECT. NO NO NO NO. AN A AND B
A AND B OKAY. SO ITEM A AND B,
THAT WOULD BE, SHERIFF BRAUN AND
SHERIFF MOON APPOINTED TO THE
PEACE OFFICER STANDARD TRAINING
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE. FOR 3 TO 0
ON CALL. OKAY I'M SORRY. 4 TO 0
ON CALL. OKAY AND THEN WE'D LIKE
TO TAKE UP ITEM. OH, SHE JUST
VOTED ON THAT ONE. I APOLOGIZE
AND THEN, ON GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR, WE TOOK UP ONE MOTION ON
ITEM TWO. Â F G H I, J K, AND
L. ARE YOU OKAY? IF WE KEEP
THOSE TOGETHER? SENATOR, I AM
OKAY, SO WE'LL JUST OPEN THE
ROLL FOR ALL. ALL OF THOSE.
EGGMAN. YES OR NO? EGGMAN. AYE.
5 TO 0. OKAY AND THEN AGAIN,
YES, IT CARRIES FIVE ZERO.
SORRY. YES, SIR. THANK YOU. I
KNEW WE COULD DO THIS TOGETHER,
CAN YOU. AND THEN. ITEM THREE
WAS BILL REFERRALS. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. 5 TO 0. THAT MOTION
CARRIES. ITEM FOUR WAS. OR.
EXCUSE ME, AND THEN WE HAD FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. ITEM FOUR WAS
FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEMS FOUR THROUGH NINE. OH,
EXCUSE ME, FOUR THROUGH NINE.
EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. 5 TO 0. AND
NOW WE WILL GO BACK TO OUR NEXT,
APPOINTEE, A GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE. WE HAVE, DOCTOR CHIMA
HERE. DID I DO THAT CORRECTLY OR
NOT? OKAY, GREAT, AND I
APOLOGIZE, JUST LIKE MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE BEEN HAVING
TO GO THROUGH THIS IN THE
SESSION, I HAVE TO STEP OUT AND
PRESENT A BILL, AND I. BUT I
WILL BE BACK AND, I JUST WANT TO
SAY, I REGRET TO INFORM YOU THAT
I HAVE TO PASS THE GAVEL TO MY
COLLEAGUE, BUT HE'S WONDERFUL,
AND HE WILL CHAIR THE REST OF
THIS. THANK YOU. THANKS. SORRY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT WAS
THE END OF THE BRIEF GROVE
ADMINISTRATION, SO WELCOME. AND
WE WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BRIEFLY MAKE AN
OPENING STATEMENT AND INTRODUCE
ANYBODY THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE WITH
YOU TODAY. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. SIR.
SENATOR IT'S MY PLEASURE AND
HONOR TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU THIS
AFTERNOON, I'M ALSO HONORED AND
GRATEFUL TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR
APPOINTING ME AS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY. I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
INTRODUCE MY FAMILY WHO'S HERE
SUPPORTING ME TODAY? MY HUSBAND
CASEY, MY DAUGHTER REGAN, AND MY
SON CADEN. WITHOUT THEIR LOVE,
UNDERSTANDING AND SUPPORT, I
DON'T THINK THAT I WOULD HAVE
REACHED THIS MILESTONE IN MY
CAREER. I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY
FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO ARE
WATCHING ONLINE. IN PARTICULAR,
MY SISTERS BALJINDER, BALJEET,
PAMMI AND TAY. THEY'RE MY
ABSOLUTE BIGGEST CHEERLEADERS
AND A BIG SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO
MY PARENTS, BALRAJ AND AJIT, WHO
SACRIFICED THEIR ENTIRE LIVES
FOR MY SISTERS AND I. EDUCATION
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF MY LIFE. AS ONE OF FIVE
DAUGHTERS OF IMMIGRANTS, IT WAS
ALWAYS IMPRESSED UPON ME THAT
EDUCATION IS THE KEY TO SUCCESS
AND EXPERIENCING FIRSTHAND THE
VALUE OF A GOOD EDUCATION. I AM
SO PROUD TO WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LOTTERY TO ENHANCE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS. BECAUSE OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL DOLLARS THAT WE
RAISE AS LOTTERY DIRECTOR, I'M
COMMITTED TO RESPONSIBLY GROWING
LOTTERY SALES TO MAXIMIZE PUBLIC
SCHOOL FUNDING, AND I'M THRILLED
TO SHARE THAT FOR FISCAL YEAR
23, 24, THE LOTTERY IS ONCE
AGAIN ON PACE TO PROVIDE OVER $2
BILLION IN SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
TO PUBLIC EDUCATION. EQUALLY
IMPORTANT IS CONTINUING TO BUILD
A STRONGER, ORGANIZATION BY
FOCUSING ON ENHANCING
EFFICIENCIES AND STRENGTHENING
WORKFORCE ENGAGEMENT. I'M
DEDICATED TO CREATING AND
NURTURING A POSITIVE WORK
ENVIRONMENT WHERE EVERY TEAM
MEMBER FEELS VALUED AND
INSPIRED. AND I THINK THAT
CONTINUITY OF LEADERSHIP IS
REALLY CRITICAL FOR THAT
ENDEAVOR. CONSISTENT LEADERSHIP
ENSURES THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN OUR
STRATEGIC FOCUS AND BUILD ON OUR
SUCCESSES AS WE NAVIGATE
CHALLENGES EFFECTIVELY. IT
PROVIDES THE STABILITY THAT'S
NECESSARY FOR LONG TERM PLANNING
AND ACHIEVING SUSTAINED GROWTH.
SO I'M COMMITTED TO LEADING THE
LOTTERY WITH INTEGRITY AND
VISION AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, WE'LL MOVE
TO THE COMMITTEE. ARE THERE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
, SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING WILLING TO
SERVE IN THIS ROLE, CAN YOU TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE LOTTERY'S
ROLE IN BEING ABLE TO DO
INFORMATION ABOUT PROBLEMATIC
GAMBLING? ABSOLUTELY. SO WE,
WORK WITH THE CDF PROBLEM
GAMBLING COMMITTEE, AND WE
ACTUALLY HELP FUND THEIR,
HOTLINE. IN ADDITION TO THAT, WE
PROVIDE PROBLEM GAMBLING
TRAINING TO ALL OF OUR RETAILERS
ONCE THEY'RE BROUGHT ON BOARD AS
RETAILERS. IN ADDITION TO ALL OF
OUR STAFF, WE LET THEM KNOW WHAT
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE, HOW TO
TALK TO POTENTIAL PLAYERS ABOUT
PROBLEM GAMBLING AND WHAT THEY
CAN DO TO ASSIST THOSE PEOPLE,
AND WHAT KIND OF DIFFERENCES DO
YOU SEE AROUND THE STATE WITH,
WITH DIFFERENT SITES, I MEAN,
DIFFERENT PLACES THAT SELL
LOTTERY TICKETS OFTENTIMES ARE A
VERY DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHIC AREAS
AROUND THE STATE. SO DO YOU DO
THINGS IN DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
AND IN DIFFERENT WE HAVE TO MEET
PEOPLE. SURE. WE ABSOLUTELY DO
HAVE DIFFERENT, INFORMATION IN
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND THINGS.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU MIGHT BE
REFERRING TO IS, THERE'S A
MISCONCEPTION THAT THE LOTTERY
PREYS ON THE POOR, AND WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT
AND KIND OF GET INFORMATION OUT
THERE, AT LEAST IN CALIFORNIA,
WE'VE FOUND THAT THE MAJORITY OF
OUR PLAYERS HAVE AN INCOME OF
$50,000 OR MORE. AND WE ARE
CONSTANTLY PROVIDING EDUCATION.
AS I SAID TO OUR RETAILERS AND
OUR EMPLOYEES TO HELP, KIND OF
SEE THE SIGNS OF PROBLEM
GAMBLING AND HELP ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES. OKAY. AND I WOULD JUST
BE REMISS, WE RECEIVED A LETTER
FROM MY DISTRICT, RELATING TO,
NOT TAKING LGBTQ, ISSUES
SERIOUSLY WHEN THERE WERE
COMPLAINTS MADE. CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT?
ABSOLUTELY. I CAN I CAN ASSURE
YOU THAT WE TAKE EVERY SINGLE
COMPLAINT VERY SERIOUSLY AT THE
LOTTERY, AND WE INVESTIGATE
EVERY SINGLE COMPLAINT THAT IS
SENT IN TO US. AND WE SEE THAT
COMPLAINT THROUGH TO FRUITION.
SO WHEREVER THE FACTS TAKE US,
THAT IS WHAT WE DO. AND THE I
THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER IS THAT MANAGERS AND
SUPERVISORS HAVE THE SAME DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS AS ALL OF OUR
RANK AND FILE EMPLOYEES. AND SO
WE WHEN THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED, WE
ADDRESS IT. BUT WE CAN'T MAKE IT
PUBLIC. OBVIOUSLY, IT'S
PERSONNEL MATTERS. AND WHEN
THERE ISN'T A SUBSTANTIATED
FINDING, UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S
NO ACTION THAT WE CAN TAKE. BUT
WE DO TAKE EVERY COMPLAINT VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND JUST ON A
PERSONAL NOTE, I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT I TAKE EVERY TYPE OF
COMPLAINT VERY SERIOUSLY,
PARTICULARLY RACE BASED OR LGBTQ
RELATED, ANYTHING RELATED TO
EEO. I TAKE THOSE PARTICULARLY
SERIOUSLY. OKAY. AND THEN LIKE
CONVERSELY, CAN YOU JUST TALK
ABOUT LIKE HOW TELL ME AGAIN,
HOW BIG IS A IS THE LOTTERY? HOW
LIKE HOW MANY, EMPLOYEES
APPROXIMATELY. AND THEN HOW DO
YOU MAINTAIN, A POSITIVE
CULTURE? CERTAINLY SO AS OF
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE 1115
EMPLOYEES AT THE LOTTERY. IT'S
UP ABOUT 300 FROM WHEN I FIRST
STARTED, WHEN I WAS CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR, APPOINTED IN 2019. AND
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU, IT'S BEEN
A CHALLENGE TO MAINTAIN THAT.
BUT WHAT WE WE'VE DONE TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE CONCERNS
ARE WITH OUR EMPLOYEES IS WE
INITIATED AN EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT
SURVEY. WE DID 1 IN 1920, AND WE
TOOK THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THAT. SOME OF THE AREAS THAT
WHAT THEY WANTED US TO ADDRESS,
WHICH WERE PRIMARILY
COMMUNICATION AMONGST DIVISION,
YOU PROBABLY MEANT 2020. I'M
SORRY, WHAT DID I SAY? 20. YOU
SAID 19, 20. OH, I'M SORRY. YES,
I DID 2020. THANK YOU, SENATOR
LAIRD WAS HERE. WELL 1920,
MEANING 2019, 2020. OKAY SORRY.
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING, AND SO
WE TOOK SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE LEARNED FROM THAT, AND WE
ADDRESSED IT. AND PRIMARILY IT
WAS THINGS LIKE COMMUNICATION
ACROSS DIVISIONS, NOT REALLY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE MISSION
OF THE LOTTERY WAS AND HOW WHAT
THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING, HOW
IT CONTRIBUTES TO THAT. I'M
PLEASED TO SAY EVEN IN, 2020, WE
HAD A PARTICIPATION RATE OF MORE
THAN 75. WE JUST COMPLETED OUR
LATEST EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT
SURVEY, AND THE RESULTS ARE NOT
YET PUBLIC. BUT I CAN SHARE WITH
YOU HERE TODAY THAT WE HAD OVER,
APPROXIMATELY 80% ENGAGEMENT
THIS YEAR. AND WE'VE GONE UP IN
EVERY CATEGORY. AND SO WE'VE HAD
THE HIGHEST, CULTURE RATING
SINCE 2010. AND SO WE ARE MAKING
STRIDES, BUT WE ALSO SEE WHERE
THERE'S AREAS TO CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE. WHAT'S ONE OF THOSE
AREAS WOULD YOU SAY? I THINK
IT'S STILL THE COMMUNICATION
ACROSS THE DIVISIONS. THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE HEARING. AND SO WE'VE
DONE A NUMBER OF THINGS TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THAT. WE HAVE,
MONTHLY SPOTLIGHT SERIES WHERE
DIFFERENT AREAS PRESENT AND SAY,
THIS IS THE WORK THAT WE DO AND
THIS IS HOW IT CONTRIBUTES TO
EDUCATION. WE'VE STARTED A
MONTHLY NEWSLETTER CALLED CLUED
IN. IT GIVES UPDATES ON EVERY
SINGLE DIVISION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT AND THINGS THAT ARE
AFFECTING THE LOTTERY TALKS
ABOUT NOT ONLY OUR SALES
DIVISION AND THE BIG WINNERS,
BUT WHAT EVERY OTHER DIVISION IS
DOING TO ASSIST. THAT'S GREAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU,
DIRECTOR, AND THANK YOU FOR
MEETING WITH ME YESTERDAY. I
APPRECIATE THAT WE WORKED
THROUGH SOME IMPORTANT THINGS. I
THINK. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSE TO MY QUESTIONS AS WELL
, THE THING THAT JUST KIND OF I
KEYED IN THIS AFTERNOON IS WHERE
WHERE IS THE HEADQUARTERS FOR
THE LOTTERY? IT'S ON 10TH STREET
HERE. IN HERE IN TORONTO. SO ON
YOU KNOW, ON YOUR EMPLOYEES, THE
1100 OR SO, ARE THEY BACK INTO
THE WORKING IN THE OFFICE, OR IS
THERE STILL A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF WORK FROM HOME? WHAT'S THE
BALANCE ON THAT SINCE, THE
ENDING OF COVID? SO, LET ME
FIRST START BY SAYING WE ALSO
HAVE NINE DISTRICT OFFICES. AND
SO OUR SALES FORCE HAS BEEN
WORKING FIVE DAYS A WEEK SINCE I
THINK WE TOOK OFF FOR ABOUT TWO
MONTHS WHEN COVID FIRST
HAPPENED. AND SO THEY'VE BEEN
BACK OUT WORKING FIVE DAYS A
WEEK. OUR EMPLOYEES ARE ALL BACK
TWO DAYS PER WEEK, PER THE
GOVERNOR'S DIRECTIVE, AND ARE
WORKING IN HEADQUARTERS AND ALSO
ALL OF OUR NINE DISTRICT
OFFICES, OUR DISTRICT OFFICES,
BECAUSE THEY'RE PUBLIC FACING,
THEY HAVE BEEN IN THE OFFICE
FIVE DAYS A WEEK. OKAY, GREAT.
THANK YOU, AND THANK YOU FOR
MEETING YESTERDAY. I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. I ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION AND A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. FIRST, WE TALKED
ABOUT THE INEVITABLE ISSUE Tð
THAT WHEN THE CAMPAIGN WAS RUN
40 YEARS AGO, IT WAS GOING TO
PAY ENTIRELY FOR EDUCATION. AND
I GO EVERY YEAR. I HAVE 2 OR 3
PEOPLE WALK UP TO ME OUT OF A
CROWD AND SAY, NOW, WHY ISN'T
THE LOTTERY PAYING 100? BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THEY HEARD IN THAT
CAMPAIGN. YOU ALSO HAVE A
CAMPAIGN WITHIN THE LOTTERY TO
CHANGE THE NARRATIVE. SO TALK A
LITTLE ABOUT THAT, ABOUT HOW YOU
DEAL WITH CHANGING THE NARRATIVE
OF WHAT THE LOTTERY IS OR HOW
PEOPLE SHOULD RELATE TO IT. AND
SOME OF THE LINGERING THINGS
THAT, SUCH AS FROM THE CAMPAIGN.
THANK YOU. I'LL JUST SHARE THAT
WHEN I STARTED IN 2019, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT BECAME VERY
CLEAR TO ME IS THAT NOT VERY
MANY PEOPLE KNEW THAT EDUCATION
WAS BEING SUPPORTED BY LOTTERY
DOLLARS, ALTHOUGH YOU MENTIONED
THAT PEOPLE COME UP TO YOU AND
SAY, I THOUGHT THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO FUND EDUCATION
ENTIRELY. I HAD PEOPLE COMING UP
TO ME AND SAYING, WHAT DO YOU DO
WITH ALL THAT MONEY? WHERE DOES
IT GO? THEY REALLY DID NOT KNOW.
AND SO WE WANTED TO CHANGE THE
NARRATIVE AND EDUCATE PEOPLE NOT
ONLY ABOUT WHERE THE MONEY GOES,
BUT ALSO TO CLARIFY THAT WHAT WE
PROVIDE, ALTHOUGH IT IS QUITE A
SIGNIFICANT SUM, IT'S MERELY A
DROP IN THE BUCKET FOR WHAT IS
NECESSARY FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION.
AND SO IN ALL OF OUR PRESS
RELEASES AND BIG WINNER PRESS
CONFERENCES, WE REALLY TRY TO
HIT ON THE FACT THAT IT IS
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION. AND SO IN, IN TRYING
TO GET THAT WORD OUT, WE'VE JUST
LAUNCHED IN 2024, A PAID MEDIA
CAMPAIGN TO THAT EFFECT. AND
RATHER THAN GOING OUT AND
GETTING PAID ACTORS TO DO THIS,
WE REACHED OUT TO THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SAID, PLEASE SEND
US INFORMATION ON ON HOW YOU
SPEND YOUR LOTTERY DOLLARS. AND
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, THE RESPONSE
HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
OVERWHELMING. WE ARE HEARING
FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS, LARGE AND
SMALL, ACROSS THE STATE ABOUT
HOW THEY'RE SPENDING THOSE
LOTTERY DOLLARS. AND SO WHAT
WE'VE DONE WITH THAT IS WE'VE
CREATED COMMERCIALS THAT FEATURE
REAL STUDENTS AND REAL EDUCATORS
TALKING ABOUT HOW THEIR PROGRAMS
WOULD NOT EXIST IF IT WAS NOT
FOR LOTTERY DOLLARS. AND PRIOR
TO LAUNCHING THIS CAMPAIGN, WE
DID A FOCUS GROUP TO KIND OF GET
AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE
PEOPLE'S KNOWLEDGE LEVEL WAS.
AND WE DID A FIRST WAVE IN
FEBRUARY AND MARCH, AND WE AGAIN
DID A FOCUS GROUP, AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO SAY THAT THE KNOWLEDGE
INCREASED AND WE ARE NOW DOING A
SECOND WAVE IN, THAT'S IN MAY
AND JUNE, FOCUSING ON ADDITIONAL
SCHOOLS. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION, I WAS VERY AMAZED TO
FIND OUT WHEN WE MET AND IN THE
DOCUMENTS THAT OF THE 39 YEARS
OF THE LOTTERY, THERE HAVE BEEN
23 DIFFERENT DIRECTORS AND THE
ONE WHO JUST LEFT THAT AFTER
FOUR AND A HALF YEARS WAS THE
LONGEST SERVING AND PROVIDED A
MEASURE OF STABILITY THAT HADN'T
NECESSARILY EXISTED. AND I ASKED
IF YOU INTENDED TO TOP THAT, AND
, AND, AND I THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE
GOOD IF YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT
WHAT STABILITY MEANS AND WHAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO BRING IN,
HOPING TO BE ONE OF THOSE LONGER
TERM DIRECTORS. ABSOLUTELY. I
DON'T THINK IT'S ANY SECRET THAT
THE LOTTERY HAS DURING ITS TIME,
FACED ITS SHARE FAIR, OF FAIR
SHARE OF CRITICISM. AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT ONE OF THE REASONS
IS THE CONSTANT CHANGING OF THE
DIRECTOR POSITION, WE'VE BEEN
TOLD BY STAFF AND EXECUTIVE
STAFF AS WELL THAT IT'S ALMOST
LIKE WHIPLASH. A DIRECTOR COMES
IN, THEY SET THEIR GOALS AND
POLICIES IN PLACE, AND THEN
THEY'RE GONE. AND THEN SOMEONE
ELSE COMES IN AND SAYS, WELL,
THAT'S GREAT, BUT I DON'T WANT
TO DO THAT. THIS IS WHAT WE WANT
TO DO. I THINK WHAT'S BEEN
REALLY GOOD ABOUT THE PRIOR
DIRECTOR AND MYSELF, I WAS HIS
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR, AND WE
BEFORE I WAS EVEN APPOINTED, WE
MET AND WE WERE ALIGNED IN OUR
GOALS FOR THIS DEPARTMENT. AND
ONE OF THE PRIMARY GOALS WAS WE
WANTED TO MAKE THIS DEPARTMENT
STRONG ENOUGH THAT IT DID NOT
MATTER WHO SAT IN THAT DIRECTOR
CHAIR, THAT WE HAD ENOUGH
POLICIES, PROCEDURES,
EXPECTATIONS AND RULES IN PLACE
THAT NO MATTER WHO WAS IN THAT
CHAIR, THE LOTTERY WOULD
CONTINUE ON THE PATH THAT WE
WANTED TO WANTED IT TO GO ON,
WHICH IS TO HAVE SUSTAINABLE
GROWTH RESPONSIBLY. OBVIOUSLY.
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND, ALTHOUGH WE SELL A
PRODUCT, WE ARE A STATE
DEPARTMENT AT THE END OF THE DAY
AND SO WE ARE SUBJECT TO CERTAIN
STATE RULES. I UNDERSTAND THAT
WE'RE A UNICORN AMONGST STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND WE DO HAVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY, BUT WHERE WE CAN
FOLLOW THOSE RULES, WE
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD. AND SO WHEN
THE PRIOR DIRECTOR TOLD ME THAT
HE WAS LEAVING AFTER I PICKED MY
JAW UP OFF THE FLOOR, I THOUGHT
TO MYSELF, DO I WANT THIS JOB?
AND THE THING THAT MADE ME
REALLY WANT TO APPLY FOR THIS
JOB WAS THE CONTINUITY FACTOR. I
DID NOT WANT SOMEONE ELSE COMING
IN AND CHANGING FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS OF HARD WORK AND I'M VERY
PLEASED TO SAY THAT I FEEL LIKE,
WELL, AND OUR SURVEY SHOWS THIS
IS THE BEST EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT
THAT WE'VE HAD AND THE MORALE
HAS BEEN SO GREAT. AND SO I HOPE
TO CONTINUE THAT. AND YES,
SENATOR LAIRD, I HOPE I FAR
SURPASSED THE PRIOR DIRECTOR'S
FOUR AND A HALF YEARS. GOOD.
WELL, THANK YOU. THAT WAS A
COMPREHENSIVE ANSWER. AND I
THINK IT, IT, IT SORT OF
ADDRESSED SOME OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS WE MIGHT HAVE. SO I
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH. DO ANY
OTHER MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE GO TO SUPPORT? I WAS
JUST GOING TO ADD MAYBE SHE'S
THE ONE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PREVIOUS, CONTINUITY. AND IT'S
GOOD THAT WE MIGHT BE CONTINUING
THAT TODAY. SO IN A WHILE I
MIGHT TAKE THAT AS A MOTION. SO,
THANK YOU. THIS WOULD BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYONE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS NOMINATION, TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND PLEASE DO IT.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. SENATORS. MY NAME IS
JOANNE GEORGALAS, AND I'VE KNOWN
HARJINDER HAJ FOR 20 YEARS. IT
BEGAN BACK 20 YEARS AGO WHEN WE
WERE ATTORNEYS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION. LEGAL DIVISION,
AND AS ASSISTANT CHIEF COUNSEL,
I WAS HAJI'S SUPERVISOR FOR TEN
YEARS. I'VE FOLLOWED HER CAREER
PATH AND HER ENDEAVORS IN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS, AND SHE'S EXCELLED
EVERYWHERE SHE'S BEEN. I'M VERY
HONORED TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
COMMENTS FOR HER CONFIRMATION
TODAY. HAJ POSSESSES
CHARACTERISTICS OF AN EXEMPLARY
LEADER BASED ON HER EXTENSIVE
LITIGATION AND CONTRACT SKILLS,
SHE IS ABLE TO THOROUGHLY AND
EFFECTIVELY ANALYZE AND RESOLVE
VERY DIFFICULT AND SENSITIVE
LEGAL ISSUES AND THAT'S THE
PRIMARY REASON WHY I OFTEN
ASSIGNED HER THE MOST DIFFICULT,
EMINENT DOMAIN AND CONTRACT
CASES TO REVIEW AND TO HANDLE.
SHE RESOLVED EVERY CASE WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT, AND SHE
RESPECTED OPPOSING COUNSEL AND
PARTIES. SHE TREATED THEM FAIRLY
IN A VERY TRUSTWORTHY MANNER.
SHE IS TRUSTWORTHY, LOYAL AND
HONEST IN HER DEALINGS WITH
COLLEAGUES, OPPONENTS, STAFF AT
EVERY SINGLE LEVEL, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THE PUBLIC. SHE
SEEKS INPUT AND THOROUGHLY
ANALYZES EACH SITUATION BEFORE
MAKING ANY DECISION OR RESOLVING
ANY PROBLEM. SHE'S DEDICATED TO
PUBLIC SERVICE AND IS PASSIONATE
ABOUT SERVING THE PUBLIC. HER
POSITIVE ATTITUDE SHINES IN
ANYTHING SHE WORKS ON AND IN ANY
ENDEAVOR SHE UNDERTAKES. YOU
SHOULD HAVE NO RESERVATION
WHATSOEVER CONFIRMING HER TO
HEAD THE LOTTERY SYSTEM, AND I
URGE YOU TO DO SO UNANIMOUSLY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY. FOLLOW THAT. I SHOULD JUST
SAY A PLUS ONE PLUS ONE,
WHATEVER SHE SAID. SO, MR. VICE
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MY NAME
IS TIFFANY ALVIDREZ AND I APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN MY CAPACITY
AS A CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY
COMMISSIONER. I FELT IT
IMPORTANT TO BE HERE TODAY TO
OFFER MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF MISS HARJINDER
SHERGILL CHEEMA AS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY,
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE I'VE HAD
THE PLEASURE OF OBSERVING HER
MANAGEMENT STYLE OVER THE LAST
YEAR. YOU'VE SEEN MISS SHERGILL
CHEEMA'S RESUME AND HEARD HER
OPENING REMARKS, SO YOU ALREADY
KNOW THAT SHE HAS DEDICATED HER
PROFESSIONAL CAREER TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AS ONE OF ITS MOST
COMMITTED PUBLIC SERVANTS. SHE
IS WELL QUALIFIED, WELL SUITED
AND MORE THAN PREPARED TO ASSUME
THE ROLE AS DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY. SHE
LOCKED ARMS WITH HER PREDECESSOR
, FORMER DIRECTOR ALVA JOHNSON,
IN THE MONUMENTAL TASK OF
REAFFIRMING THE LOTTERY'S
COMMITMENT TO MAXIMIZING ITS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION, AS WELL AS PROVIDING
A CLEAR FRAMEWORK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO OPERATE WITH
TRANSPARENCY, INCLUSION AND
EXCELLENCE. HE DID A PHENOMENAL
JOB OF CHARTING THAT COURSE WITH
HIS MISSION, VISION AND VALUES.
I BELIEVE MISS CHEEMA IS THE
RIGHT PERSON TO CONTINUE THAT
MOMENTUM AND EXPAND ON THAT
VISION. SHE IS WIDELY RESPECTED
AND HAS A LEADERSHIP STYLE THAT
IS CLEAR AND DIRECT. MISS CHEEMA
HAS APPROACHED THIS OPPORTUNITY
WITH HUMILITY, TÊ A HUMILITY AND
A RESOLVE THAT ARE REFLECTIVE OF
A SERVANT LEADER'S HEART. I HAVE
EVERY CONFIDENCE IN MISS SHIMA'S
ABILITY TO LEAD THE LOTTERY IN A
WAY THAT WILL MAKE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PROUD FOR THOSE
REASONS, AND MANY MORE, DO I
OFFER MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF HARJINDER
SHERGILL CHEEMA AS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY?
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. WE APPRECIATE
IT. ANYONE ELSE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT? SEEING NO ONE, THIS
WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYONE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE. THEN WE WILL
BRING THE MATTER BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS OR
ACTION. I WOULD MOVE THAT WE
ADVANCE THIS CANDIDATE TO THE
FULL SENATE FLOOR. PERFECT. WE
HAVE A MOTION. THAT'S HOW YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO, SING. NO
DISCUSSION. I WILL ASK FOR A
CALL OF THE ROLL. MAGUIRE. GRAY
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. JONES
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. AND LET ME COMMENT THAT,
BOTH SENATOR GROVE AND SENATOR
MAGUIRE INDICATED THEY'RE
GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE. THEY DON'T
NOT NEED TO RETURN FOR, PUTTING
THIS ON CALL. SO I WILL DECLARE
THAT MOTION PASSED 3 TO 0, 3 TO
0. CONGRATULATIONS. YOUR
NOMINATION WILL BE ADVANCED TO
THE FLOOR. AND THEN, IN A
MOMENT, WE'LL GO TO CLOSED
SESSION. BUT WE HAVE THREE Kò
THAT ARE ON CALL. ONE A, B, AND
C THAT ARE ALL FOR ZERO. AND THE
CHAIR HAS INDICATED HE IS FINE
AND WILL NOT BE RETURNING. SO
LET IF I DON'T KNOW HOW WE NEED
TO DO IT, BUT LET'S CLOSE THE
ROLL ON ALL THREE OF THOSE, IS
IT WHAT DO YOU NEED TO DO TO DO
THAT, JUST DECLARE THAT THE ROLL
IS CLOSED 4 TO 0. THEN I WILL
DECLARE THE ROLL IS CLOSED ON,
1ABC THAT WITH EACH, THE VOTE
STANDS AT 4 TO 0. AND THE,
NOMINATIONS WILL BE ADVANCED TO
THE FLOOR. SO WITH THAT, LET ME
THANK EVERYBODY FOR OUR
UNUSUALLY, SHORTER THAN USUAL
MEETING. CONGRATULATIONS TO THE
PEOPLE WHOSE NOMINATIONS HAVE
BEEN MOVED ON. AND WE HAVE ONE
EXECUTIVE SESSION ITEM. SO WE
WILL, GIVE EVERYBODY A CHANCE.
IT'S NOT THE IMMEDIATE STAFF, TO
LEAVE THE ROOM AND MOVE TO
EXECUTIVE SESSION. SO THE
PUBLIC, PORTION OF THIS MEETING
WILL, STAND ADJOURNED. THANK YOU
ALL.